现在大家看一下我66年前的一个眼部状态
我也觉得很重
而且还有类估
眼周有些找训文
然后很体内的
我现在的也不状态
我今年是31岁了
首先这个误采是非常紧知的
也没有增加多的那种小训文了
像现在是又做账号又做直播
我已经是比几年前
要类很多的
但是这个眼部状态真的是没有拉垮
我今天就是分享一下
我是怎么样
保养我的眼周的
大家不问人的眼周的问题
我黑眼圈看起来很逼悖啊
种旁啊
都是由于长期熬夜以及过渡用眼
导致我们眼线
非常非常的鱼堵
所以俩了眼部状态
好只要做好牌主
循环出通
眼部状态就可以好很多
那第一点就是我非常非常建议
现在大家把小时候
我们做的那一套眼暴建策
重新做起来
其实现在网上很火的那个眼部玻斤
它就和我们小时候做的眼暴建策是一举同工的
而且做眼暴建策
你不需要知道什么
去语语啊
你不需要买什么玻斤棒
就有手就能做
眼暴建策
它就可以放松
我们这一圈的眼部机肉
以及加速我们眼周的循环
这样色素它就不会那么容易约在一起
我们就没有那么容易长黑眼圈
还有经常按模眼周的话
可以保持眼睛
是你跟亮睛睛的招牌
但我现在也是保持了这个习惯
只要我觉得会眼周
今天很皮老的话
我就会做眼暴建策
但是要注意一定不能干挂
一定要配合一个眼双
或者是眼油来一起挂
这样就不会在做的时候
过度拉成到眼周
而长的那种小细文
第二个就是
通过热服家压
让眼睛把更多的眼样给吃进去
不习惯的时候用那个热水
把这个习惯进来吃
然后服在眼周
其实就可以了
就很简单很方便的说
睡觉之前可以服一个真信照
第三点就是
一定一定要好好选眼双
从我高中
我就开始用眼双了
就是便宜的贵的
用了很多很多
我发现很多眼双
它躲下来
就是一个保持效果
好像躲了一个新的眼睛
搞的我之前以为
是不是眼双就是一个
很机会的一个产品
但是
真的不是
我发现眼双真的是有区别的
我根本分享
这个眼双
自身堂他们家月威的
小争管着眼双
这个真的就是让我
非常非常的经验的眼双
二一年我就开始用了
我就当时用了
没有多久
我就发现
我的眼圈蛋了
我的眼闻眼蛋了
我以前
化了妆之后
我就要废了
我既然来折我那个
眼圈折我这个眼下的
这个类钩了
多美车化完妆
我眼下的这个地方
就显得很厚重
然后非常的卡粉
但我用了他之后
发现轻轻松松
我随便用了粉底
我眼下
一点都不卡纹了
我还不是博助
我当时就是觉得
这个眼双真的太好用了
因为他我发了我第一条
想问出
当时就是要好多好多的路人
刷到了这一条
然后就跑到我那个评论去说
他这个眼双
我也有用
他忘记好问我什么
医生推一句种伙
还跟我身边
所有所有的女性朋友
全部都安定的就眼双
他们家这个新版本
比之前更好用了
就是他的制定
依然是那种
很信念
很资问的
但是你用他
以完全不用担心
说会长指防力
他非常非常好吸收
我虽然连上很游
但是我的证言周
是那种
沙漠大干脾
非常需要这种
右资论
但是右很好吸收的眼双
所以我用的时候会用他来搭配作
研报检藏
就很适合
就会拉扯到眼中
他里面是有A纯的
而且是那种
很有静的实力派
不是那种
慢慢来的那种温吞型
右一段时间就会感觉
眼周的那个小细文
真的是带了很多
然后眼周的肌膚
真的就是那种
仅仅的崩崩的那种
眼部状态会让他变得特别
还有资深堂他们家
那个白白成粉
他这里面也是家了
所以用他
也相当于是用了一个很厉害
牛的白精华图在那眼中
那种色素型的
可以据用他也可以改善很多
再加上这个A纯的家识
就可以让眼周肌膚变得很嫩
很亮
意语其他部分的那种亮
让眼睛真的是看起来
神产意义性的人
精神状态特别
而且用他我的
类估也评了很多
应该是他里面
封配的植物交远统
可以碰续我们皮膚
自己多长一点交远
那我们那种类估
A纯的地方就碰起来了
变不像你平正之后
真的会写的人年轻好很多
就你看一照都感觉
非常非常的上镜
然后那个皮背
感一点都没有
怎么拍
那个眼部状态都很好